we've also figured out by the way why
disney has gone so insanely woke
because i couldn't figure it out i
thought
yes all the corporations are going woke
now but why is disney in particular
disney where the bread and butter of
this company is families as kids is
normal people it's not even the woke
crazy coastal elites it's normal people
in the middle of the country who for
whatever reason decide to spend
thousands and thousands of dollars going
to a theme park in florida or california
where they can wait for seven hours to
go on two rides i don't get it it's not
my thing but a lot of people love it and
the people who love it are normal people
they're not radical ideologues so
why are you going to flip them off why
are you going to have your company now
say
you can't engage with our product
because we're going to trans your kid
we're going to steep them in radical
ideology what was the thought process
well now we've got a little bit of of
information on it the disney heiress
charlie disney has just come out as
transsexual
this woman
who's a woman but who thinks that she's
a man is a high school teacher she
critic criticized the florida parental
rights and education law
saying these children the gay children
and the transgender children and the
pansexual and all these
the children that she believes have this
extraordinarily firm sexual ideology and
identity she says they can't learn about
their community and their history at
school
or play sports
or use the bathroom that they want to
use
yeah that's true
at least the last part of that is true
the last two parts yes the little boys
can't use the girl's bathroom
i hope actually now they probably can in
lots of places but they shouldn't be
able to
it's disordered and weird for little
boys to go use the girls room at school
and the heiress to disney who's got
disney right there in her name is crying
about this
she says i haven't told people this
before but i'm a transgender and i've
always known and this woman's mother
apparently told the los angeles times
that from the age of two onward
charlie
was pulling away from the girl's shoe
section at the department store and
saying but mom i'm a boy on the inside
so i in a way i sort of feel bad for
this woman she's a grown woman now
charlie disney but her mother's
obviously a complete lunatic too who
believes that a two-year-old can pick
her own sex
and so she was raised in this it's a
very personal issue for her and it's
probably the biggest challenge
conservatives have on this transgender
issue on sexual issues generally is
people take it really really personally
and so you can sit them down over a nice
cup of tea and say listen i've got
charts i've got graphs i've got a white
board behind me
boys
not girls and you can speak in the most
elementary simple logical terms that you
can and that's probably not going to get
through because people are going to
interpret that as an attack on their
identity the left loves this the left
has always tried to make politics
personal this was the slogan of the
second wave feminists in the 1970s they
said the personal is the political
if we make our personal lives
right down to who does the dishes right
down to who cooks dinner if we make that
a big political issue open to public
scrutiny and if we make public political
issues extremely personal and say that
if you oppose a radical political agenda
you're a hateful terrible monster who
wants to kill me
if we can do that it's going to be much
easier to get our radical agenda through
the conservatives aren't going to know
what hit them and they're going to have
a harder time arguing against it because
our political agenda will be immune to
facts and logic
that's what they're after and they've
done a pretty good job of this
i'm glad you like that clip now i'm just
i'm gonna make it very simple ring that
bell subscribe get the notifications
check out the other videos you can also
get the audio podcast on apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play at the
michael knowles show leave a five star
review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]